Elise said I let go of my snooze button
it's a struggle but I'm getting more
done in the morning now than ever you
know what I realized it I don't even
send an alarm anymore if I go to bed
early I wake up early yes it's like it's
just how my body is programmed I was
talking to when I did the health
problems podcast I was talking to dr.
Tommy wood and Christopher Kelly about
this and and ice actually sleep more now
than I did well certainly more than I
did invite my 20s because I I wore it as
a badge of honor I slept for hours last
night what are you lazy people do what I
can do on four hours of sleep yeah I can
look how healthy I am look what I can do
in this unhealthy state back so I were
talking about this yesterday I think the
the the second biggest contributing
factor to me improving my health and you
can go back and listen to that episode
episode 138 but it was the longest
podcast that we've ever done but it's
because we had all these little
different segments about sleep and
exercise and and chemical sensitivities
and libido and erectile dysfunction and
like all of these different discussions
we had little five-minute discussions on
so it was almost like having 15
miniature podcasts all sort of
sandwiched together I have with with
both of them but what I was talking to
Beck's about yesterday is I think sleep
is the second largest contributing
factor to my improving my health and
making sure I'm getting seven to ten
hours of sleep a night yeah now now I
say seven to ten because two nights ago
I got I got 10 hours of sleep my body
needed it and I mean ER I woke up before
and I'm like okay I'm ready to get up
and start writing and I'm like am I
really and I said okay I'm gonna give
myself permission to get back in bed for
a half an hour and just sleep and see if
if this is my Bunny's and I did that
again today I got up around 4:45 and am
i okay I'll give myself until about 5:30
and at 5:30 if I'm still awake then I'll
get out of bed and I'd that's what I did
and I wrote for an hour I did some
exercising and so it's like it's letting
your body be the alarm clock it's sort
of what you were talking about yeah
and letting your body determine okay
last night I only needed seven hours but
maybe tonight I need more because it was
a strenuous day or whatever yeah I
noticed Baxter's really working hard now
on her she's like training again so like
she is like crazy crazy fit right now
just doing a lot of endurance and like
CrossFit style sort of workouts and so
she and a cardio on top of it but as a
result she requires more sleep and you
know Ella she's a tornado every night
though she sleeps for 11 hours sometimes
12 hours a night so jealous I wish I
could sleep that many hours but here's
the thing
also maybe if I was a tornado for 12
hours a day then I would need that that
kind of thing I remember I think it was
Roger Federer it was definitely tennis
player but he was Federer who said if I
don't get at least 11 hours more likely
12 hours then there's a problem and so
what he's saying is I have to sleep half
the time because of the energy I expend
and so yeah letting go of the snooze
button is one way to do them
you